dude I almost got my rocks off I was
just looking for a massage and rolled
into the wrong part
oh come on and a couple homies go oh
[ __ ] it's Brendan Schaub what it is and
I'm here to get a real massage yeah yeah
just so you guys know even though I have
coconut in my hand coconut butter you
know I came with not just cash I brought
cash and found this on rub met Tom and
I'm wearing sunglasses in a hoodie
doesn't mean that I'm here to get
dragged off illegitimate yeah I'm here
for a real massage the massage was real
but I'm pretty sure I'm wearing a robe
right now I'm pretty sure as a
rub-and-tug place and I'm the dumbass
that came that for a real massage oh boy
I knew it's fake she was like you tell
she just trying to figure things out
she's taking my foot like this like for
five minutes like this and she didn't
she did this one yep
I hadn't had that you could see her just
looking at the clock trying to waste the
hour like what else are we gonna do cuz
I had this [ __ ] yeah
thinks I know what the [ __ ] I'm doing I
had a woman she was she put oil on me
she was massaging my legs Oh
yep and I was like and I was like like
she's looking at me and then she she
began to you gonna stroke my [ __ ] and
and and I was like what's going on and
she had oil and she was like you want
extra I go I go I don't know I'm tense
yeah she goes you won't be and I go I
guess I'll give you extra I think this
is legit because and then she goes do
uh-huh and I go I mean all the extra
that would I don't know I don't have it
work I don't know how it works who was
in America I don't know where I go oh
yeah yeah like this oh that lock on
Katie they go Oh cuz I was like a downer
and I was like oh this is this legit so
I didn't know I don't know either and I
was like why she wearing a necklace hey
is it any different than rubbing your
feet like pleasures pleasure right the
question isn't it get nice massage
anything better
well you know you can massage my feet we
can't massage my your bring out that
till you're bringing up a very important
question
it plays you're so good to rub my butt
feels so good to rub my legs my now like
that old but I'm not allowed to have I'm
not allowed it would be a sin if I if it
feels so good in this area like between
below or my bellybutton is right above
my below my pubis bone and right where
my taint is that are your thighs good
you can't touch that area that's my
I don't care who you are you start
running around my thigh or blood it goes
let's ride yeah he goes I HOD he goes ha
no you'll sound the alarms it's the fire
station the boys go down the pole time
to wake up already but it goes like a
ladder does it sound like that who you
are yeah and then sometimes even if
you're at Massage Envy where it's a
professional place yeah LIGO turnover
yeah and you start rubbing my legs
uh-huh they just got it yeah they're
just like this is my dick trying to
finish the massage oh yeah yeah figure
it out bro oh yeah um but yeah it was a
regular place but I was embarrassed when
I was walking out the guys go
oh [ __ ] branch I went hmm I want you to
be very clear I'm not here to get jacked
up I had a gal who used to come to my
house back in the day who would massage
me kind of a real earthy I tell you this
story
yeah real earth of the other boys too
earthy crunchy crunch yeah sweet sweet
girl who doesn't love her
yep and then one day she just hopped on
yeah and I was like what okay I guess
that we're doing this and then I told my
buddy that yeah and then my buddy
assumed what I was saying was she does
that so he told his buddies so she made
the rounds and she was doing that making
Bank - making Bank and I guess she got
into the whole Hollywood crowdin and
then I don't know what happened but I
had a lying mite advertently probably
yeah or is one of those gals all Baba
you think you were the first a dumb
woman you think you first said she was
massaging jumped on a cop because it was
for a long time it was legit ya know and
she lit up like because you never really
made a run but as soon as as soon as
this you went ten-hut she just jumped on
I think that's just no it wasn't sexual
first she was probably just hey it was
completing the media my guy that thinks
the strippers real name is cinnamon yeah
yeah oh you need money you gotta get out
of here you've kids what's your name /
Stephanie that's a great name Wow let me
get this straight
you got to pick names and that's what
you pay a pirate I all pirate way from
here
yeah where are you from here in Vegas
lots of difficut more create a [ __ ]
well I'm hiding from baby you trying to
go to nursing school yeah it's not my
favorite well I'm getting my degree no
you're not
yeah yeah would you master these nuts
yeah exactly I gave her 500 bucks
because she says he's gonna come over
later yeah okay I'm sure she will yeah
yeah this is massage place is shady
donating super shady strip clubs all but
also who cares who cares if dudes are
growing and getting the rocks off
they're paying for it as long as that
woman's not held like that there is no
like I have sexual prisoner yeah yeah
seemed cool might be dying on the inside
though you know mmm well what would you
say no Tommy self-regulate she act off
like a cow I used to have a place in yep
I used to have a place in Venice and I
came across a runaway a runaway Korean
gallon I'm not joking and she came and
she was walking and I saw her she was
holding some stuff in her hand and she
was in a was it massage loose-fitting
like a very what looked like essentially
something she'd worn you know it was
like in a club you know and I went and I
she goes hello she goes do you know I'm
looking for a bus stop she asked him
something and I said where have you been
just going on with my finessed no I was
with my buddy I was a crew runaway and
it was so obvious that she wanted to get
somewhere so my buddy goes I think this
girl's in trouble bro my buddy Bob and I
go I'm I don't know and she doesn't know
I think she's in trouble
so I said excuse me she started to walk
it excuse me to turn around and go are
you do you know where you're going do
you know what's going on she our feet
were dirty and everything else and I
know that it wasn't junky stuff this was
something and she said oh I'm just
trying to find some friends and you know
I was like this is very Shady I said
please come in I said you need to make a
phone call
long story short long story short what's
really long my buddy goes she took a
shower at our place
listen this she was in there for to the
point where was like an hour where I
knocked on the door make she was okay
comes back out
and the desperation on her face I gave
her 250 bucks she called me an angel
never saw her again
Jesus we have finesse bro I don't think
was finessed I think something true run
away from one of those rub things I
think bro no $200 got it no it's not
outward she was trying to get away maybe
you know it was weird man it was weird
it was like oh you're in real trouble
here so many places are a little weird I
was found chin this I was t-mobile in
the place next to it's a massage parlor
his happy endings yeah and a SWAT team
went and they're literally ready oh yeah
why wasn't I mobile yeah well they took
some old guy out look like a politician
he's going you were having sex with her
like yelling at her they let all of them
go to wait who was saying that the SWAT
guy was saying that to the dude who's
[ __ ] damn yeah I watched every bit of
it like a movie Wow and then I get I
just kept repeating shouldn't it be out
like fighting real crime or some of them
right right leave guys alone the old
house like should they be fine real crap
no one participated in it but they get a
tip sometimes some girl escapes and goes
hey girl that's why I can't get out and
I said maybe it's like a real sex
trafficking ring or maybe this is like
some cartel [ __ ] have to run in so like
that and those guys are real but I just
kept saying God you think they'd have
something better to do than bust these
guys am i right yeah am i right nothing
because I've been devotes yep am i right
yeah it was long mmm Yeah right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]